[Applaudissements]
ils ont familiale en rouge des ailes a
pris tout le monde en otage pour
raconter une anecdote à votre avis je
dirai pas ce qu'elle est assez folle
pour ça qu'elle a volé une voiture pour
l'école étaient ses bonnes réponses
la bonne réponse était la réponse gay
pendant 24 heures 20 48
oui les ouïes de marquer 24 et 48
ah oui j'avais 48 sur ma fille c'est
donc 48 heures qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ben on avait un chien qu'on a donné moi
j'avais décidé de retrouver mon chien de
gens entraînés deux petits copains au
passage vous aviez calage et 7,1 et
comme j'avais repéré le trajet avec mes
parents j'ai refait deux jours pendant
7o mais vous avez mangé comment vous
savez on sait on a bouffé des raisins
sur baby des trucs super acide et tout
et tout julien je joue pendant trois
heures durant à pleurer mais on a fini
par revenir en a raconté nouveaux
parents devaient être mort de thembi
pelles et surtout les flics avaient
commencé à draguer le drac et l'isère
des deux grands fleuves du coin et donc
comme j'ai raconté une histoire de
personnes qui nous les kidnapper j'ai
pris une rouste comme jamais dans ma vie
les nerfs de ma mère on là je vous dis à
dieu de nous en mettre une deuxième hors
primes et pendant tout l'été le gogo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mais finissent et ce en quoi j'ai
une adolescente une adolescence super
calme un super
lors de mes courses maritime
isabelle s'est fait attaquer par
christophe carrière à des poissons
volants baie des cochons sauvages
c'est un ours blanc dès le captain igloo
lors d'une course maritime isabelle
s'est fait attaquer par quoi on est bien
d'accord que si jamais je gagne je n'en
porte pas avec moi quand même non ben
non je vais aller de réponse c'est quoi
nous recevons blanc un ours blanc répond
c est la réponse était la réponse des
cochons sauvages des cochons sauvages
comment ça s'est passé
maritime oui bah oui sur un raid en mer
de chine le soir reste à fixer